woher kommt das ganze wasser auf werden
tatsächlich eines der spannendsten rest
unserer erde hat es irdischen ursprung
oder kam das wasser aus dem all auf die
erde
nun gibt es eine neue studie dazu dass
der ursprung allen lebens demnach mit
gigantischen mastställen aus dem weltall
zu tun hat und welche gesetzmäßigkeiten
dafür leben im weltall bedeutet dass
jetzt endlich zum tanzen fiction
herzlich willkommen
wie die erde entstanden ist darüber
herrscht in großen teilen der
wissenschaft konvent man ist sich einer
meinung doch ein teilaspekt dazu nämlich
die sogenannte wasser frage wird unter
wissenschaftlern und
wissenschaftlerinnen immer und immer
wieder neu infrage gestellt und
diskutiert denn so klar es ist dass ein
großteil der erdoberfläche mit wasser
bedeckt ist so unklar ist wo um himmels
willen das ganze wasser der ozeane
flüsse und seen und der eiskappen
eigentlich verkommen nicht einmal final
geklärt ist ob es auf der erde selbst
entstanden ist oder ob es aus dem kosmos
stammt und wie soll es dann wohl auf die
erde gelangt sein ein rätsel das
gleichzeitig auch den ursprung allen
lebens und somit auch unsere existenz
beinhaltet super spannend ist deswegen
nicht nur das aktuelle studienergebnisse
auch arizona auch die vorhergegangenen
versuche vieler verschiedener
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
eine plausible antwort auf die große
über allem stehende wasser frage zu
geben ist von spannung und dramatik kaum
zu überbieten zu vergleichen tatsächlich
mit einem krimi immer auf der suche nach
neuen indizien um der frevel endlich zu
lösen wie so oft gibt es auch bei der
wasser tragen zwei verschiedene lager
einige forscher und forscherinnen
vertreten die these dass die erde seit
ihrer entstehung wasser enthält und das
wasser in unseren ozeanen und füssen aus
dem inneren des planeten stammt demnach
soll das wasser schon von beginn an in
dem material enthalten gewesen sein auf
dem die erde vor langer zeit einmal
zusammenklumpen das wasser weil zunächst
im gestein eingeschlossen und seien dann
als gas aus dem magma ausgeströmt und
flüssig geworden es ist die erste
hypothese zum ursprung des wassers auf
der erde doch liegt unser erster näht
dafür nicht viel zu nah an der sonne
würde die hitze der sonne
die entstehung solch gigantischer
wassermassen auf der erde zu lassen oder
würde ihre intensive strahlung ich dazu
führen dass der großteil des wassers
sofort verdampft was zudem gegen diese
erste hypothese zum ursprung des wassers
auf der erde spricht ist die annahme
dass sich die erde in ihrer frühzeit
vermutlich in einer wasser freien region
des sonnensystems nämlich im inneren der
mars umlaufbahn
kunden haben muss das argument der
schneegrenze führt dazu dass ein
großteil der wissenschaftler die zweite
jetzt folgende hypothese zum ursprung
des wassers auf der erde vor
demnach sollen aktuellen oder kometen
aus den äußeren bereichen des
sonnensystems bei einem aufprall auf die
erde
das wasser geliefert haben sowohl
kometen als auch aktien bestehen zu
einem großen anteil aus wasser so dass
tatsächlich keine krassen einschläge von
nöten gewesen sein müssten um die menge
an wasser die sich auf unserem planeten
befindet bereitzustellen
doch die spannende frage lautet wo
genauen sollen diese kometen oder
asteroiden hergekommen seien ein
anhaltspunkt dafür kann die chemische
analyse des wassers liefern dass man
innerhalb von zu untersuchen asteroiden
oder kometen findet um das dann mit der
chemischen analyse des erd- wasser zu
vergleichen so war so das ziel der
astrophysiker klar formuliert finde eine
region im sonnensystem in der aktuellen
oder kometen mit einem ähnlichen
isotopenverhältnis vorkommen denn das
könnte dann gleichzeitig auch der
ursprung des terrestrischen wassers
seien im jahr 1961 kam übrigens zum
ersten mal die these auf dass wohl
kometen das wasser auf die erde gebracht
haben sollten nur um es voller zu
verdeutlichen seit 1961 sind schon ein
paar jahre ins land gezogen und noch
heute im jahr 2017 gibt es keine finale
antwort auf die wasser frage die kometen
theorie als antwort auf die wasser frage
über dauerte dann knapp mit 20 jahre bis
dann in den 80er jahren der hallesche
komet der aus der orten wolke stammt
genauer untersucht vor der ergebnis kurz
zusammengefasst die zusammensetzung des
wassers viva cometen stimmt mit der
wasser zusammensetzung auf der erde
überein das fazit der wissenschaftler
und wissenschaftlerinnen nur ein
bruchteil unseres wassers auf der erde
stammt wohl wenn überhaupt von kometen
aus der ortsmarke das ist diese riesige
wolke um unser sonnensystem noch reichen
diese befunde aus um kometen als
wasserlieferanten der erde aus dem
rennen zu schicken
der wissenschaft könne jedenfalls weiter
als max planck forscher mit hilfe des
weltraumteleskops herschel eine gruppe
von kometen identifizierten die app
quelle für das wasser auf der erde
durchaus in betracht gezogen werden
können die jupiter familie
jetzt auch die untersuchten das
verhältnis von schwerem zu herkömmlichen
wasserstoff isotope und haltet euch fest
die analyse dieser
isotopenzusammensetzung hatte dann
tatsächlich ergeben dass das wasser auf
diesen kometen mit dem wasser auf der
erde übereinstimmt dies ist ja wohl ein
starkes indiz dafür dass diese kometen
als außerirdische wasserquelle gedient
haben könnten
oder etwa doch nicht soweit nun also ein
paar der wichtigen meilenstein im großen
rettet und um die wasser frage
nun kommt eine weitere theorien zu und
bricht eine weitere lanze für die
aktuellen fraktion im fachblatt science
schreiben wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen aus arizona und
jetzt das wasser durch asteroiden auf
die erde gekommen seid die sich in weit
außen liegenden bereichen des
sonnensystems entwickelt haben müssen
dort außerhalb der sogenannten solaren
schneegrenze habe die sonne eine nicht
so hohe strahlkraft auf eis verdampft
die eben nicht anders als auf den
sogenannten jugend planeten wie der erde
der venus und dem mars die durchaus
näher an der sonne heranwuchs nach
berechnungen der wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen kreisten diese
aktionen damals als [ __ ] um die
sonne und hatten zum teil mehr als 100
kilometer durchmesser bei ihrer
entstehung wurde in ihrem inneren wohl
auch das radioaktive aluminium 26 mit
eingeschlossen
denn dies war damals zu einer sehr
großen menge im sonnensystem vorhanden
die so entstandene radioaktivität führte
schließlich dazu dass das eis der erste
ideen schmolz und diese zu so genannten
kollegen konkreten erstarrten eine
mischung aus wasser und festen gesteins
körnern also und um es ganz korrekt auf
den punkt zu bringen schlaf als einige
damals auf abwegen mit der erde zusammen
breiten warten wir den aktuellen
studienergebnissen zufolge aber noch
mehr als nur wasser mit lebenswichtige
elemente nämlich wie schwefel stickstoff
und kohlenstoff sie gleich alt wie das
wasser selbst vorher kaum oder gar nicht
auf der erde vorhanden waren die aber
als grundlage des lebens selbst eine
ungeheuer wichtige rolle spielen somit
noch einmal auf den punkt zu bringen
ohne diese elemente die nach ansicht der
astronomen und astronomen wohl erst
durch die gigantischen flamm bälle auf
die erde gelangt waren
dettl eben wohl nie entstehen können was
hört ein großartiger zufall ist das wohl
endlich die lösung zur vieldiskutierten
wasser frage es gibt wissenschaftler
kollegen und kolleginnen die den
aktuellen erklärungsversuch aus arizona
freundin für plausibel halten denn
forscher und forscherinnen konnten
bereits im vorfeld zeigen dass das
wasser in diesen kollegen konkreten wer
dem wasser auf der erde ähnelt und
wieder zeigt sich offensichtlich ein
naturgesetz ein naturgesetz der
entstehung von leben auf den heißen
entstehenden planeten kann es offenbar
überhaupt keine zutaten für leben geben
sie bilden lediglich den gesteins kern
ist er entstanden müssen dann aus den
äußeren bereichen eines sternen systems
konkreten und kometen auf die planeten
stürzen damit die bausteine des lebens
überhaupt vorhanden wenn sie bilden
quasi die lebensspendende schicht um den
toten gesteins kern wahnsinn welche
gesetzmäßigkeiten sich daraus ergeben
würden wenn es so ist dann ist eben
wirklich der normalfall im weltall wir
können also gespannt sein wann und ob
wir andere leben auf fremden planeten
tatsächlich finden werden wir halten
euch dazu natürlich hier und auch zum
thema wie das leben auf die erde kam auf
dem laufenden wenn ihr kein video
verpassen wollt dann wird mir hier ein
abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
genau und hier geht es weiter zum thema
mit kam leben von kometen auf die erde
erdrutsch auf tory wenn ihr euch mehr
zum thema informieren wollt dann klickt
unbedingt drauf und ansonsten bestand
bleibt dran